So laws related to online activities
in particular are malicious
online activities.
So, things like theft and extortion.
Of course are illegal
in the physical world.
We talked about data theft.
Someone hacking into your computer,
walking away or siphoning off
your sensitive data, using that to take
on your identity is identity theft.
Gaining access to your financial
accounts or getting credit cards and
things like that,
it could even be extortion,
from locking up your computer to
doing a denial of service attack,
saying your website won't
be up unless you pay up.
You would think those kind of criminal
things that happen in the cyber world,
we should have laws related to those.
And we going to see that
actually is the case in the US.
The other set of laws have
to deal with copying and
distribution of digital objects.
So these digital objects are
essentially, your intellectual property.
It could be software.
It could be other kind of content
like music, videos and so on.
And if it's your intellectual property,
we know that in the known distal world
we do have intellectual property.
And we have ways to protect those.
And the way we do that is through
copyrights or patents and trade secrets.
So question is,
do these also apply when it comes to
digital objects that we access and
manipulate in the online world?
And if there are,
we do need to have these kind of laws,
how exactly do we apply them?
There's something different
about the online world
compared to the physical world.
So how exactly, for example, copying
something could be extremely easy.
That may not be the case
in the physical world.
So, if you do have we allow someone
to copyright a digital object or
protect it.
Well how exactly the law will be applied
is a question that you might have.
The other thing that, we actually not
going to talk a great deal about it,
is the idea of privacy.
We do all of things online.
So our activities online
what exactly we do,
what websites we visit, what services
we access, what do we search for.
It's very easy to collect all the kind
of information about these activities.
These are my activities and
somebody else can collect
information about what I do.
Are there any laws that protect me, in
terms of what kind of information could
be controlled, how could it be used?
There are actually, I said we'll get
through some of these, but not all.
But the idea of privacy here is that
the internet allows, it makes it
possible at a scale of magnitude
that we have never seen before.
So, the idea of Big Brother for example,
somebody knowing everything that you do,
is there something in the laws
to protect me from that?